was geht hier ist euer marx und herzlich
willkommen zu diesem neuen video ich
habe festgestellt dass mein katjas
kommentare video ziemlich abgegangen ist
und irgendwie 750.000 klicks hat oder so
was dazu geführt hat dass er
irgendwelche komischen gestalten auf
meinen kanal gekommen sind die ziemlich
viel mist in meine kommentare
geschrieben haben und deshalb dachte ich
mir heute gucken wir uns mal die
kommentare an die so unter dem katjas
kommentare video hinterlassen wurden und
ich kann euch sagen es wird lustig es
wird die label und es kommt einiges
herum und ich würd sagen wir fangen
einfach an mit numero uno ich zeige euch
heute zehn stück und ja nummer eins ist
von tobias er schreibt meine fresse du
bist so dumm okay du warst wie dich
sollte man auf den scheiterhaufen werfen
du sparst what the [ __ ] was habe ich
getan ich habe einfach nur die
kommentare vorgelesen von leuten die
sich absolut behindert benommen haben
wir im internet
und nun tag für mich auf den
scheiterhaufen werfen und ein fetter
spaßt wenn ich auch noch bin ich dick
leute ohne schreibt einen kommentar und
er schreibt den kommentaren voll viele
leute ihre nummer gepostet haben unter
diese katja krawiec instagram bilder und
ich habe mich ein bisschen drüber lustig
gemacht er schreibt er leute ich bin
sexy ruft mich an 110 also der ole ist
ein kleiner scherzkeks aber live druck
auf jeden fall aber das habe ich sogar
öfters winter angelesen kommentar nummer
3 von pimp also ich hab das alles müssen
zensiert so dass sie nur direkt über
geht und die leute dafür dass sie so
behinderte sachen schreiben bisschen
rostet er schreibt nämlich schon traurig
was für ein schlechter youtuber man sein
muss um nacktbilder auf das video zu tun
um überhaupt views zu kriegen erst mal
mein lieber freund das war kein akt bild
was sie auf mehr gemacht habe sondern es
war einfach ein stinknormales foto von
ihrem instagram und generell viele leute
haben sich darüber aufgeregt dass ich so
ein foto auf haben mehr gemacht habe
klar ist ist katja witte habt ihr schon
mal ein foto von der mit viel klamotten
gesehen wo sie irgendwas an hat also was
kann ich noch nicht auf mich nehme ich
kann doch nicht stunden oder tage damit
verbringen irgendwo im internet ein foto
von ihr wo sie normal angezogen ist und
nicht irgendwie auf reisen begleitet
finden was erwartet ihr von mir ich bin
ja auch nun youtube ein bisschen green
schreibt hässlich mehr kann ich nicht
sagen ich weiß nicht ob ich so ein video
nochmal machen kann will das trifft mich
halt einfach viel zu sehr wie die ganzen
röhre gewann dadurch zu lesen egal gebe
zum nächsten kommentar er ist von
priscilla geschrieben warum genau hat
dieses video eine altersbeschränkung und
katja es nicht leute das habe ich mich
auch gefragt ich finde es einfach
vollkommen abstrus also wirklich die
redet in ihren videos von anfang bis
ende nur von sex ist angezogen wie in
porno und mein video wo ich mich einfach
nur darüber lustig macht wird als
beschränkt ich hab's auch nicht so
wirklich gecheckt aber ja also keine
ahnung ich verstehe es nicht so recht
aber die meisten von euch schlängeln
haben sowieso accounts wo sie älter sind
als 18 uhr 20 prozent meiner zuschauer
sind unter 18 laut man analytics und das
stimmt ja wohl irgendwie nicht aber ja
also aber die frage wirklich hab ich mir
auch gestellt jetzt schreibt sie
irgendwas halbig zensiert wer geld damit
macht indem man die kommentare anderer
youtuber kommentare vorliest gutes
deutsch hatte es nicht verdient also
wirklich das ist sind diese behinderten
nichtskönner die solche kommentare
schreiben es ist doch kein böse
kommentare vorlesen gewesen ich hab
einfach dieses phänomen wie es auch im
video gesagt habe gezeigt dass einfach
die leute da in den kommentaren so
vollkommen durch sind und sich komplett
krank benehmen und der sand habe ich das
video gemacht ja nicht weil ich selbst
keine kommentare habt du vogel hier
glückwunsch du bist in meinem kommentare
vor ließ video aber wirklich mal also
solche kommentare habe ich so häufig
gelesen unter dem video und wollt ihr
was wissen
ich habe damit nicht mehr geld verdienen
mit dem video ab dem zeitpunkt wo es
altersbeschränkung was ungefähr nach
vier stunden
der fahrer habe ich nichts damit
verdient und in den ersten vier stunden
ist das video nicht so gut abgegangen
sondern erst nachdem es als beschränkt
wurden also ich hoffe ihr seid alle
glücklich nächstes zum beispiel viel
mehr wert ich habe über das video halt
einige leute auf meinen kanal ziehen
können und die sind jetzt noch dabei
also auch wenn du neu bist herzlichen
dank dadurch viel mehr abonnenten
zuwachs bekommen das ist mir jetzt
wichtiger als irgendwie das geld von dem
video so nächster kommentar von florian
auch so häufig gelesen er schreibt
scheiß faker und ich habe das so so
häufig gelesen wie gesagt die leute
schreiben alle steigern wisst ihr warum
weil ich krank crafter heiße und weil
luca von crafter heißt wir sind einfach
die leute die kommentieren bevor sie
sich informieren entweder du gehst auf
meinen kanal und sie ist okay der hat
gestern vorvorgestern video mit luca
hochgeladen und dann trägst du a ha wird
er wohl einfacher sein wenn die beiden
gute freunde sind
nein wahrscheinlich würde kein fähiger
sein oder aber du informiert sich
einfach weil mein name war damals ein
schock einfach zusammen mit luca wir
dachten so jemand weiß dass man da
empfängt
so das war einfach ein dummer witz
damals und die leute schicken sie
einfach nicht und schreiben 1000
fachkräfte von crafter fähiger leute
crafter ist nicht so eine seltenheit
zunächst der kommentar von nico er
schreibt wäre dieses fairplay nicht wäre
es ein wirklich gelungenes video und hat
100 likes darauf und ich denke mir da so
wäre dieses vom nil nicht vom playlist
das bild was da ist wenn man aufs video
klickt wäre es ein wirklich gelungenes
video und dann denk mir so ok das bild
für das video und das video selbst sind
zwei komplett unterschiedliche sachen
wie kann das bild einfluss auf die
qualität des videos nehmen überhaupt
nicht also voll viele leute haben sich
darüber beschwert also wirklich erstens
wenn ich schon über die rede
dann nehme ich auch nur ein bild
zweitens ist es verdammt schwierig
überhaupt ein anderes bild zu finden und
drittens ist ändert verdammt noch mal
nichts an der qualität vom video wenn
den leuten das gefallen hat ihm scheint
sehr gefallen zu haben dann ist das
video an sich noch nicht schlechter weil
ein anderes bild davor ist als du gerne
hättest meiste ja dass ein bisschen
strange ok nächster kommentar sven dafür
interessiert du dich pornos nichts
anderes du [ __ ] what the [ __ ] sven
komm runter
nein ich interessiere mich auch für
andere sachen glaubst oder glaubt nicht
übrigens seit ich vorgestern mein abi
bahn hatte
an dem tag keine zeit videos zu machen
gestern weil ich den ganzen tag über ein
bisschen fertig und deshalb kommt es
heute wieder was aber jahres wenn ich
danke dir für dein kommentar die letzten
zwei worte kann ich nur erwidern und wir
gucken uns die nächsten kommentar an und
zwar schreibt leon
ich mag dein gesicht richtig also deine
haare meinte jetzt marke die haare in
meinem gesicht also meine augenbrauen
und wimpern oder meine haare weil meine
haare sind jetzt nicht mein gesicht
lieber leon aber whatever ja ich fand es
auf jeden fall sehr lustig das video hat
einige leute angezogen die ihr gesehen
habt ziemlich ein trash in die
kommentare geschrieben haben wenn es
euch gefallen hat das video und ihr
vielleicht noch mal ein keine ahnung
video im stil von katjas kommentare
sehen wollt wo ich mir die kommentare
von irgendwelchen anderen klischee
youtube anschaut dann schreibt das in
die kommentare
morgen gibt es auch noch ein lustiges
video und dann will ich sagen macht es
gut bis zum nächsten mal und danke dass
sie den letzten zeit so cool sein